okay now actually let's talk about one
more goodie which is the auc remember we
saw the auc for class data
classification data is the area under
the curve it's a very useful measure of
the accuracy of a classifier
well it turns out for survival analysis
there's something called the c index
which gives you a nice analogy to auc
it's an appealing method for assessing a
fitted cox model on a test set or
actually any survival model but we'll
show it here for cox model
so what do we do well we calculate the
estimated risk score for each patient
from the cox model so just like the
publication data for example
we got coefficients
and for each individual or in that case
each study we calculated the estimated
risk score
called eta hat of i i's indexing an
observation
and then what's called the c index or
harrell frank harrell was the inventor
of this concordance index
computes the proportion of pairs for
which
essentially the model gets the order of
the observations right so what we're
doing here is this is on a test set
so reach test observation we compute the
predicted risk and we compute this think
of any two pair of individuals or
studies
one had a longer event time than the
other
and for those observations for the model
to be correct we like the risk for that
the patient to live longer to have to be
lower right because lower risk means you
live longer
so this essentially says this is the
proportion of pairs that we get in the
right order among those that we whose
order we know and that's kind of a
mouthful but let me let me parse this so
among all observations for which
y i is greater than y i prime so the
survival time for patient i was greater
than that for y i prime
this is the proportion
for which the risk for i prime was
estimated to be greater than that for i
so this is correct right if the survival
is longer we want the risk of the
patient to live shorter to be larger
times delta i
the delta is doing here because for some
patients for example we can't determine
in the test set
uh which one survived
longer if for example one patient was
censored at nine months the other
patient died at 10 months
we don't know who lived longer right
because the one who who censored nine
months could have lived past 10 months
so only certain pairs can we actually
determine which event occurred first so
we only we only count up over those that
we can compare right so again it's
trying something you need to digest
but it's trying to make use of the
censoring observations whenever they
have information that we can use
basically
so yeah so i say it in a nutshell it's
proportionate pairs for which the model
correctly predicts the relative survival
time
among all pairs for which this can be
determined
so again this yeah you sort of have to
parse the notation but that's the
flavor of it
and
for the publication data we computed the
c index
and it gave .773 it's over a test set
remember so
roughly speaking it means that the model
can predict with 73.3 accuracy which
paper of a pair of papers will be
published first
so it's kind of interpretation very much
like the
auc in in classification it's very
popular yep
okay so that's
basically it we're just going to wrap up
with some topics which are in the text
if you're interested in pursuing them
the sensor we talked about is actually
the sensoring on the right
but there's other kinds of sensoring
there's left and interval censoring
which with the information you get on a
patient is not just
truncation or sensory on the right but
it can occur at other times during the
study
and the models we've seen actually all
the statistics we've talked about
survival curves log rank tests cox's
model can all deal with
left and interval sensoring other kinds
of censoring
sometimes the choice of time scale is is
interesting
normally one uses calendar time but if
you're looking at a patient's age and
how their age affects their survival you
might index time by age
and other other things so
this is a topic that comes up sometimes
time dependent covariates are something
which are somewhat unique to this area
in all the examples we've seen in most
examples actually in regression right
you measure covariates or regressors
once for an individual and they're fixed
they're a static thing but in some
survival studies you follow patients in
time and you measure things like their
blood pressure at different time points
so maybe it's a five year study and you
see them every month
well at the beginning you get their
blood pressure
but every month you measure their blood
pressure and another very nice feature
of the cox's model is that it can
actually it can capture the effect of
the time-varying covariate which you
measure because remember in those risk
sets an observation would be in several
risk sets as we're moving along in time
and
their contribution to the risks that
involves their features well if their
blood pressure has been increasing that
should be reflected
you know you know in future times we see
them in the risk sets and it turns out
to be particularly easy with cox's model
because it's sort of a sequential in
time construction you just use the
current value of x of the feature at a
given risk time risk and it's it's
really quite easy but there's a lot of
very nice statistical theory that's been
also been developed
with cox's model anti-independent
covariates
and then
we talk a little bit about checking the
proportional hazard assumption which is
important other things we talked about
in the book briefly
uh we've talked really about cox's
proportional hazards model which is a
linear regression analog of
for survival data but some of the other
learning methods you talked about in the
course random forest boosting and neural
networks have their own ways of dealing
with survival data some of which avoid
the proportional hazards assumption so
these are becoming more popular and
really currently under development
finally i mentioned terry thurnow the
author of the survivor package so let's
talk about software well the examples in
this chapter were all done using terry's
survival package as well as the glimnet
package in r and both these can handle
some of the things we've just talked
about about all the things we've talked
about plus time dependent covariates
other forms of censoring
and there's other software in other
languages of course of course there's
other software in r
the models other kinds of survival
models
and also in python in the scikit
survival python collection in other
places